[Music]
a russian entrepreneur has put a one
million dollar bounty on vladimir
putin's head that's too cheap bro
one minute oh
one million ain't gonna kill him does he
know about the oligarchs in russia dude
there's so much money in russia
billionaires dude one million dude
that's so i guess i guess this guy's
[ __ ] up for putting only one million
out there you know what a [ __ ] idiot
guess what yeah guess what putin just
did he just raised all the salaries of
the guys around it to one million and
one dollars oh
we're conflicted now
god damn it
i'm making more money with putin
one dollar more that's very cheap wait
is he oh uh is he in russia i don't know
if he's in because that's dangerous
right that sounds like his name this
guy's name i'm gonna butcher his last
name his name is alex konnaniken
is off korean konami code is offering up
the incredible sum of cash obviously not
incredible here to whoever is able to
capture the kremlin leader dead or alive
in a post on linkedin
the former banker hopes the incentive
will see putin taken into custody and
the war with ukraine ended
he wrote that would end the war he wrote
i promise to pay one million dollars to
the officer
or officers who complying with their
constitutional duty arrests putin as a
war criminal under russian and
international laws that's that's a
caveat right there he is a very
honorable man so you can't just like
freaking throwing knife the guy you have
to do it under the constraints of like
the law i'm i'm assuming that if you
were to throwing at the guy and he died
and you like dragged his body he'd
probably still be able to claim the
prize i feel like he'll they'll go ah we
can't give it to you because the
technicality of what i said
but then if you slap her okay i guess
complying with their constitutional duty
but that that's already up for debate
right yeah but
can't he i wouldn't charge for murder
because he paid somebody to kill
somebody
i guess that's why it's saying complying
with a constitutional duty arrest yeah
that's a war criminal so it's more like
a prize under russian international law
so it's almost an actual bounty
you know what i'm saying it's a prize
yeah can i just do that on anybody
because what if i'd be like i'll give
you 50
right now to go and grab
the
whoever is the [ __ ] interior of labor
or some [ __ ] but are they a war criminal
under an international law the interior
of labor i don't know if that's a
department
that guy's like what did i do i'm just
the interior of labor
he's like this isn't even a job
why am i going away it's a fake title
okay so this guy claims
putin is not the russian president as he
came to power as a result of a special
operation of blowing up apartment
buildings in russia then violated the
constitution by eliminating free
elections and murdering his opponents as
an ethnic russian and a russian citizen
i see it as my moral duty to facilitate
the denotification of russia i will
continue my assistance to ukraine in its
heroic efforts to withstand the
onslaught of putin's order tight
that's tight
i i made fun of a guy that's actually
doing good in the world
let's get that department of education
head right the head of the department of
education he works right next to the
interior labor guy
your interior
paper that sounds like a governmental
role right
interior if you had to give him a job
role what would he do
department of labor education
that's what what labor the this guy i'm
talking about the interior guy the guy
you want to offer instead of him yeah
labor like
picture hanger dude like yeah like dude
he's he's definitely choosing whose jobs
are what
okay you know like you're an actor
you're a builder
you make coffee mugs
he chooses jobs yeah he chooses yeah
picture hangers are real [ __ ] i just
realized it's a real thing what do you
mean picture hanger i met i met this guy
like i was at starbucks in hollywood i
met this guy rolled in with a nice ass
car we just started chatting and i was
like what do you do man he goes i'm a
picture hanger and then did you go
no way
[Laughter]
i said get real bro
you get real
all he does is when rich people buy art
he just hangs it on their wall for them
maybe he just has like really good like
he doesn't even he could see level yeah
he can level
he just has the power to level every one
try it's like the guys on like [ __ ]
ig that you see real quick they're like
going to the chalkboard in prison or
whatever they draw a perfect circle why
can't you just do this
he said he's been doing it 28 years and
every day he'll have like four to five
clients because
doing it so long in hollywood it's all
word of mouth he doesn't have like any
advertisement all he does is whenever
someone buys nice art at auction or
something they just call him he comes in
and he literally just hangs it
or installs the like that a picture
hanger that's what he said yeah he
hasn't come up with a [ __ ] term for
it that's even better that he calls i'm
an art arranger
interior labor
interior
honestly though like imagine [ __ ]
like going in an auction or whatever
paying like a million plus dollars on a
piece of art like i'm gonna be like
who's the pro yeah yeah exactly all this
[ __ ] is that is [ __ ] very [ __ ]
true well dude me and nick you want to
get a chandelier and apparently you
gotta buy a [ __ ] elevator just to get
the goddamn chandelier up there uh oh
like a scissor lift you install like
this thing up there and then it can it
can go down and like you hook the
chandelier and it goes back up like
automatically does that mean that you
have control of it like that that
machine is in your house so you can
always like
because my house is so [ __ ] big now i
got a [ __ ] huge ceiling and now i
can't just reach this thing and you're
huge holding i know it's annoying it's
funny how does it feel like to not be
able to hit the touch the ceiling of
your like own home that's weird to be
honest rich
that's so rich so have you ever been
able to touch the ceiling of your home
joe doesn't even have a home
he's homeless i'm literally homeless
i don't
it hasn't worked out so good
life hasn't worked out so good for joe
see the so the difference here is that
you guys uh you guys stayed in crypto
and i sold it you know and
so uh the um
original post on linkedin featured a
poster showing putin's face in the
middle alongside a text that said wanted
dead or alive for war crime did a
[ __ ] cowboy hanging on a little
saloon wall
that would honestly be kind of sick
though that'd be pretty cool it'd
probably be a meme though you wouldn't
take a series but at the end of the day
if it's like a million dollars imagine
if you're like in putin's court right
like you're just like one of those
random like security guards a random
[ __ ] you're not really a somebody you're
not one of the oligarchs right and then
there's like a legitimate bounty and you
kind of don't believe in what's going on
i'm just trying to hypothetically put my
mind yeah yeah yeah you can get that
close
and get away with it you probably don't
need a million dollars yeah exactly
like if you're that close to him
you think so even like
what about his driver
i don't think he'll get away with it
that's the thing but the second you kill
him like what is there anything to get
away from what if like you kill him and
then again hypothetically don't come
after me vladimir dude the way people
like vladimir consolidate power though
is they take out all their political
opponents and then they scare the shadow
you by being like hey if you ever hear
some [ __ ] we're gonna take you out if
you hear you hear anybody saying some
[ __ ] guess what we're taking them out
it's like i think they just for fun
everybody says those things and what if
this is the top guy that's passing down
that well the the closer you are the
closer you are to him you just die every
couple of months you'll be like
you're too close oh yeah then he just
kills you okay the only one who can kill
him is an american hacker who can make
his cell phone explode when he's holding
it here that's it but he doesn't talk
i think he tells people have you seen
the tables that he does his meetings
with they're like 20 [ __ ] feet long
and all of his people are over there and
he's talking to him like it's like
coming to america
so like he's by himself on one side
everybody else is super far away you
should see the pictures it's hilarious
the beauty and the beast when they're
drinking that sugar soup oh yeah yeah
and he's got a mirror to the left so he
can only see what's behind his back
he has those sunglasses that have like
rear view mirrors
guess what i see your ass is coming dude
from 20 feet away
the pixelated ones where he's like a
homie
so would you say putin is very uh like
he's very paranoid of people trying to
kill him
i would imagine if you're kgb you're
paranoid no matter what he's like i
don't think everyone really hates me
people like me right
people hate me
do you think this was too harsh do you
think he does those conversations
the international criminal court has
already announced it will be
investigating russia over possible war
crimes committed following the invasion
of ukraine and icc chief prosecutor
karim khan revealed in a statement that
he believes alleged war crimes and
crimes against humanity have been
committed in ukraine and an
investigation into russia's actions will
be launched as rapidly as possible which
technically if it's official that war
crimes have been committed then the
bounty's real
now do bush and cheney
give me a break dude all this posturing
is so [ __ ] awesome what are you
saying man what are you saying with
business
big time big time a million people dead
in the interest no no
international community is coming to
[ __ ] put anybody on trial just saying
because you're hella rich with like you
know chandelier elevators you should put
out a bounty on linkedin for bush and
[ __ ] no no i'm sure i'm joking
if you're listening right now just
playing some places i am willing to give
you 20 because that's all i have left 20
damn but that means a lot to joe though
it means the world to me
twenty dollars
maybe a spear
oh that's your good spirit [ __ ]
offer
all right i'll give you twenty dollars a
spear and a hat and fake money son of a
[ __ ]
died if you can take
george george bush jr
dick cheney okay
and um let's get him to stand for the
war crimes did you guys see how he got
heckled recently by a vet it was pretty
[ __ ] nuts so he was uh doing a
uh uh speech uh george uh w junior
junior bushy right and then um
junior w bushy right
[ __ ] george bush my friends died for
no [ __ ] reason i
oh i lost all my friends because of the
iraq war you are a war criminal all that
and in the very beginning before people
said before he was like um i'm a veteran
you set me there for no reason everyone
was buoying him they're like boo and he
goes i went to iraq for no reason
everyone shut the [ __ ] up
oh because he's a veteran they thought
he was just some stupid hippie protester
but he's like
but isn't that isn't that stupid because
the stupid hippie protester has the same
message yeah i know right so it's like
okay cool it is stupid but it's like all
of a sudden because he's a veteran i
mean it makes more sense he gave his
life to protect his country but then we
all know it's like well not really it's
because the bush family and the cheney
team wanted to profit like a
[ __ ]
that's what sucks man and they're not
gonna get in trouble for it no no in
fact they get to talk about ukraine
right now and they are yeah that's the
so [ __ ] annoying just gotta put a
bounty on linkedin let's put them down
in there okay i got 20 bucks how much
you guys got uh 20 bucks and a spear and
a hat don't [ __ ] retrace your entire
thing yeah i'll give that that's what
i'll do the super bowl winning i'll
sacrifice my super bowl i lost the super
bowl i probably should have i would have
won if i bet it on the points instead of
the straight win
but i'll give you my losing went lotto
ticket
i'm a legend this guy what a lord of
life
[Music]
[Music]